hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
new plans to channel water company
pollution finds directly to the
environment rather than the treasury
the boss of British gas owner centrica
tells guy news he wants more government
help to create the world's largest green
Storage Company
and the Woodland trust calls for the
planting of more resilient trees as it
reveals storms took down 30 000 Acres
last winter
[Music]
good
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now the government has announced plans
to use fines handed out to water
companies for polluting scenes and
rivers to directly help improve the
natural environment it follows a number
of cases during the summer when
untreated sewage was discharged directly
into the sea money from fines imposed by
off what or handed out following
environment agency prosecutions is
currently returned to the treasury the
water Minister has told us the new
policy will make a really big difference
it's well over 100 million since 2015
has been taken in in these kind of fines
so it's significant money which will
make a really big difference when it's
used out in the environment this is just
one measure in a huge raft of measures
that we are taking to tackle water
quality and quite clearly water
companies know that the writings on the
wall and that pollution incidents are
totally unacceptable
let's bring in our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue now so Ali
they say a really big difference
well look I think this is something that
the conservatives have definitely been
under a lot of pressure on earlier this
year we had the Parliamentary
environment audit committee they talked
about chronic under-investment that they
blamed for the country's dirty Waters
they said that pollution caused by
sewage single-use Plastics agriculture
was leading to what they called a
chemical cocktail that was making our
Rivers very dirty indeed and that is
something that at the time Rebecca
Powell who you just heard from the
minister said that she welcomed she said
it highlighted the work that the
government is doing to try to fix that
but there is still pressure this is
still something that's coming up on the
doorstep and pressure too on on the fact
that legally binding targets that were
due to be set there's been a delay to
that happening and that is something
that Therese coffee the environment
secretary said is disappointing here's
what Rebecca Powell had to say about
that delay we shouldn't have been those
targets but we're working across the
board at PACE to get them out but what
we do need to make sure is that the
right target so a huge amount of work
has gone on behind the scenes with
consultation with stakeholder workshops
working with all the parties that will
have to actually carry out the reaching
these targets so we need to make sure
they're right we're virtually there and
they're going to be announced very very
soon and when it comes to fines for
pollution incidents that we've been
hearing about I think there's no doubt
that that will be a significant amount
of money potentially the environment
agency since 2015 have retrieved a total
of 141 million pounds worth of fines so
that money now not going to the treasury
but instead going to projects to help
clean up our Waters is going to be a
positive thing but that doesn't mean
that pressure's going to weigh this
going away this is something that's come
up again and again it came up when I was
in Chester a couple of days ago ahead of
the by-election there tomorrow the lib
Dems say that this is a pathetic attempt
to save but I think what we're seeing is
the government trying to squarely put
the blame at the doorstep of water
companies but they know it's something
they need to get to grips with okay Ali
thank you
while also making climate news today
more than 30 000 Acres of Woodland were
damaged across Britain by storms last
winter that's according to data
collected by the forestry commission it
says that more than 90 percent of trees
which fall are replanted but it is
calling for landowners and Forestry
managers to plant more diverse and
resilient tree species that can better
withstand the extreme weather brought
about by climate change along with new
pests and diseases
just stop oil protesters have issued a
call for the England Captain Harry Kane
to wear an armband carrying their
message at the World Cup the group has
also threatened to escalate its campaign
of direct action previously they've
thrown soup and paint at famous works of
art which are protected by glass glass
screens but now they say they'll
consider slashing masterpieces in an
echo of action taken by the suffragettes
German companies have signed a 15-year
deal to buy liquid gas from Qatar as the
country looks to wean itself off its
dependence on Russian gas but the
arrangement raises questions over
Germany's commitment to a carbon neutral
energy Supply it also comes despite high
profile protests against qatar's human
rights record by the German football
team and ministers during the World Cup
now the UK has started to draw gas from
a recently reopened huge gas storage
facility under the North Sea as cold
winter weather sees an increase in
demand for heating but the chief
executive of British gas owner centrica
has told Sky News that what is really
needed is more government help to
convert the storage from natural gas to
hydrogen creating the world's largest
green storage facility our business
correspondent Paul Kelso has been
speaking to Chris O'Shea at the
easington gas terminal in Yorkshire
so today while we're standing in the
easington gas terminal this terminal can
process 20 of the UK's gas demands but
the brilliant thing is if you go out
this way 20 miles out to sea is the
rough storage facility that's the UK's
largest storage facility it's stopped
operating its storage in 2017 and we
reached after the earlier this year
today's Monumental because this is the
first day that we've been withdrawing
gas from the facility to put into the
system so as you can see there's not
much wind today it's quite cold and so
there's a higher demand for gas and
roughs working exactly as it should you
were asked to open this up by government
was it a mistake with hindsight to have
shut it down so in 2017 we found some
issues with some of the wells offshore
some safety issues and we looked at the
cost of refurbishing the entire facility
and the cost of that was prohibitive
based on what the market said at the
time and so we're operating this reduced
capacity what would really like to do is
to get the right regulatory framework
with government so that we can bring
this fantastic world-class facility back
to fuel capacity not only to store
natural gas but also to store hydrogen
hydrogen is the key to the UK's
decarbonization but in order to have
people adopt or have people start to use
hydrogen you've got to have a place to
store it rough could become the world's
largest hydrogen storage facility
well let's speak to Paul he joins us now
and Paul how feasible would it be to
change the storage facility Well you can
do anything with money but the first
hurdle that you have to get over is uh
Chris Ocho referred to there is the
financing of any kind of development or
expansion of the rough storage field to
be clear it's a storage facility what it
means it was a gas field it's Sandstone
buried three kilometers down underneath
uh Salt Rock so it's sealed It's a
Wonderful
um feat of geology entirely accidentally
that produced lots of methane gas which
has long been burned and now can store
methane gas has pumped back into it it's
about 20 percent of its capacity to get
it up to 100 of capacity for natural gas
would take about a billion pounds to
convert it for hydrogen storage would
cost centrica estimate and these are
very rough figures about two billion
pounds you need to replace all the steel
in the wells that go down into the
ground to pump the as it will be
hydrogen in and out the steel that's
being used at the moment is of not
sufficient grade for hydrogen it's a
much smaller molecule than methane
that's the issue you'd probably have to
raise and start again with a new
terminal at easington where I was
talking to associate what eccentric I
want is a funding agreement with the
government similar to that which is
provided for building a nuclear power
station or actually is used for the
interconnectors that connect the UK to
the gas Grid in Europe whereby you would
set a cap and a floor as it's known so
there will be an upper price on the
energy that centrika is able to sell
from uh from the rough facility hydrogen
and future methane down the line and a
floor on how low the price could go so
if the price of gas drops hard to
imagine but if it did the government
reimburse uh centrica for that money and
if it went above a certain level all
that excess profit as we are seeing at
the moment would go back to the
government and that would give a
financial uh climate in which Central
could say they could invest because they
know they would get a return on the
money the government there was some
conversations about this uh they're
stalled at the moment it hasn't gone
away but it's going to require that kind
of long-term thinking and probably some
kind of taxpayer involvement
underwriting of these projects as it is
across the energy transition to get
something as ambition as as ambitious as
a huge hydrogen story storage facility
off the ground the aim those Chris Ocho
told me is to produce energy security
and an energy transition because the
situation we're in today he told me
we're seeing fossil fuels being burned
just to keep the lights on
every winter you've got a worry which is
what will the weather be like so today
it's cold and it's not very windy the
cold means that people need more gas to
get their homes and the fact there's no
wind means we need more gas to generate
electricity now National Grid in the
government have worked to back up
whereby they've got coal-fired power
stations that are on standby actually
they're operating today nobody wants to
be burning coal but we've got to make
sure that the lights stay on
at that corner of homicide where I was
talking to Chris Ojo is remarkable not
only have you got easington there with
20 of the UK's gas storage you've got
the uh pipeline from nor Wheaton from
Norway 1400 kilometers long makes
landfall next door that provides about
30 of the UK's gas but that area if you
add in t side produces close to 50
percent of the UK's CO2 emissions
because of all the heavy industry what
Chris O'Shea was talking about there is
moving towards Greening that industry
there's a Norwegian carbon capture
pipeline uh being worked on at the
moment that could perhaps bury lots of
that CO2 emission so if the energy
transition is to happen we will see it
not just in improvements in the way
energy is provided we could see in a big
reduction a necessary reduction if the
UK is going to have any chance of
hitting its Net Zero Targets in the
emissions from that very industrial but
crucial corner of the UK Paul thank you
and Tom Heap will be looking at the
issue of hydrogen power for his climate
show this week and you can watch it here
on Sky News at 3 30 in the afternoon or
at 7 30 in the evening on Saturday and
Sunday
and if you have any questions about
climate change that you want answered
send them all to us using this QR code
and we will try to answer as many as we
can on Tom's show